à la météo on vous fait la trottinette
vous sont sans voix à reykjavik en
islande où cet homme de 70 ans retraite
il ya perdu son emploi et puis s'est dit
qu'est ce que je ferais bien
alors il a décidé de ramasser les mégots
par terre au sol pour nettoyer la ville
à 170e anniversaire il a reçu de
l'argent dans y'a pu s'équiper acheter
l'équipement et puis alors il a décidé
d'occuper ces journées justement à faire
ça tous les jours pour nettoyer la ville
on voit 586 parce qu'il est con mais en
dix semaines il en a rarement il en a
gratté comme ça j'allais dire vingt
mille dix mille dix mille boule de gomme
quand même pas mal ça tient occupés fini
profil
oui parce qu'on n'est pas sensé j'étais
saoul chewing gum
n'est ce pas alors c'est désagréable
dans ce à quoi le soulier c'est pas bon
aussi à des oiseaux qui peuvent manger
salon non non non c'est pas vraiment pas